In these truly trying times,
many people may be struggling
with depression, anxiety,
and other mental health issues.
Unfortunately, there
is one very widespread
mental health issue that
isn't often discussed.
Luckily, there's a new medication to help.
[Announcer] Are you
experiencing extended periods
of happiness?
Feeling little to no anxiety?
Still looking on the bright side?
Something must be
seriously wrong with you.
Given everything that's been going on,
you should be freaking out.
Luckily, Realitrex is here to help.
Once daily Realitrex is a pro-depressant
and anxiety-inducing medication
that gives you a healthy dose of reality
to get your head out of your ass
about everything that's going on.
Before Realitrex, I used
to walk all around town
with no mask on.
Now, I realize we're in a
pandemic and death is everywhere.
Didn't really get the Black
Lives Matter protests,
but after I took a Realitrex,
I thought is America super racist?
Turns out it is. (chuckles)
Thanks for Realitrex.
[Announcer] Side effects include
understanding what's really happening,
increased sensitivity
to what's been going on
for a long time,
and diarrhea.
Realitrex, the safe scientific
way to remind yourself
how awful things really are.
Now available in blueberry.